good evening and welcome to the
Exploratorium this evening and to
everything matters tales from the
periodic table tonight we are doing the
element selenium now I hope that you all
you all have your collectible card with
you this will tell you not everything
you need to know about selenium but it's
a really nice collectible card and if
you had been here for the last thirty
three months you could have collected
the entire set from starting at hydrogen
which is where we first began and last
month to arsenic and we add the new
element selenium this month who's been
after dark before Wow okay so we have a
really good crowd here who knows after
dark tonight again we're going to talk
about selenium I've expect this will
last 30 or 40 minutes I never know
because I've never done it before so
hopefully we'll we'll get this going
real soon so selenium is found right
there on the periodic table it is
element number 34 34 is it's atomic
number it's how many protons are in the
nucleus of the atom it has variable
number of neutrons in the nucleus which
we'll talk about in a little bit and it
was discovered a good long time ago it
was discovered by these two fellows
simultaneously but separately Johan
Gottlieb Gahn and John young jakob
berzelius and they both discovered it in
1817 they noticed that it was similar to
another element that had just been
discovered one called
tellurium tellurium has actually named
after the earth tellurium kind of looks
like this it's a similar to selenium
they discovered selenium in the kind of
a tailings of refining elements
pyrite pyrite is iron sulphide but
selenium is a is a an impurity in that
and when they received some of pyrite
from mine nearby the foul and mine and
they did this refining they had leftover
this red precipitate and that red that
red precipitate they assumed was arsenic
actually but when you heated it up and
here's where chemistry has changed a
little bit when you heated it up
it smelled like horseradish you wouldn't
do that today
that's why a lot of the original
chemists died from their discoveries but
arsenic did not smell like horseradish
when it was burned so if they had a clue
that it wasn't or horseradish but it
wasn't as arsenic but it was arsenic
smells like garlic I've never smelled
arsenic either but thank you for that
and I'm not likely to either but the
similar odor to tellurium told them it
might be in around the same group so
that was a it was discovered from that
they named it now we had tellurium which
was named after the earth and selenium
was named after from the Greek Selene
which means of the moon and so that
comes down to us now as selenium
selenium actually does occur naturally
you can actually find it natively here's
a piece of native selenium there's
another one it's the purple part there
so it does occur naturally but it's not
doesn't occur naturally and great enough
quantities that you would mine it that
way still has to be refined from things
there is by the way a mineral that's
called solenoid or saline it-- that that
mineral is also known as satin spar and
or desert rose or gypsum however the
thing about this is that there's
actually no selenium in it this is
actually calcium sulfate so but it has a
nice
name that's related to her element
tonight selenium is refined from the
tailings of copper so selenium really
kind of starts with some of the same
minerals that we find copper in Azure I
adore malachite or actually you can
actually find native copper laying
around on the ground as well but
normally you don't find native copper
again not a commercially viable way to
get copper you have to take it and
refine it usually electrolytically you
pull it from solution using charges and
here's a modern copper electrolysis
apparatus and so when you take the
copper out of solution you leave stuff
behind and in the tank that these copper
electrodes were in you build up a sludge
at the bottom of the tank and all that
sludge is stuff that's not copper and
it's actually called anode slime and
then you can take that a node slime from
the bottom of the tank here and further
refine that and so they get selenium
this way the selenium has a couple of
different forms at our room temperature
and pressures this is two different
forms of selenium these are called
allotropes and allotropes are really
they're both selenium they're both these
are both pure selenium and you can
convert them to each other by heating
them up and cooling them down in various
ways red selenium which I don't have a
sample of and gray or black selenium
those are both they're both the same
thing both selenium solid pieces of
selenium might look like this it's not a
very expensive element it's recently
kind of spiked in price it was down in
the 20s and it's recently kind of spiked
up to $65 a pound but that's still not
super expensive it's used for a few
different things
most of the selenium is used in
metallurgy mainly for refining other
metals and most of the other is used for
glass manufacturing we're going to talk
about some of this stuff 10% for Agrico
sir 10% for chemicals and pigments we'll
talk about that too a little bit in
electronics and other uses 5% it's not a
real common element here we see that as
a proportion of elements in the universe
it's the 31st most abundant element in
the universe so it's not up there it's
not hydrogen helium it is it's it's
moderately rare not much of the universe
about three million seven percent of the
universe is selenium oddly like I think
we've seen this before in the Sun there
is no selenium where did it go - I can't
find a really good answer for that I can
only assume that in the synthesis of
elements that happen within the Sun that
selenium gets used somehow and used up
in meteorites this actually has the
highest abundance of anything that I in
my charts here it's actually the 25th
most abundant elements in meteorites in
the Earth's crust it's pretty pretty
rare the 69th most abundant element in
the Earth's crust only five millionths
of a percent but a lot of it has gone
into the water of the ocean so here we
can see that in the oceans it's actually
quite a bit more abundance the 35th most
abundant element in the oceans and last
but not least we have to think about us
here in the human body it's not super
rare you can see it's down there near
the end I mean it's pretty rare it's not
super abundant but you can see there
it's about five millionths of a percent
of your body and we'll talk a little bit
more about that as well originally
although there's none in the Sun it's
not made in our Sun it is made in stars
it's made in exploding supernova so it's
may the fact that there's selim on the
earth means that the earth must be you
know not a first-generation planet it's
made from the
debris from exploded stars as is because
actually you see all of them a lot of
the elements there are made from the
debris of former stars the I mentioned
that selenium has 34 protons in the
nucleus but a variable number of
neutrons and things that have differing
number of neutrons but the same number
of protons are called isotopes so there
are 30 isotopes of selenium that's a lot
of isotopes however there's only five
stable non radioactive isotopes and here
they are
so selenium now this number here is 74
and that's the total number of particles
in the nucleus so protons plus neutrons
selenium 74 76 77 78 and 80 are all the
stable isotopes of selenium so these are
the ones you find in nature but you find
them in different proportions let's take
a look at that
not another one kind of snuck in there
that's in magenta down here we'll get to
that so you can see that most of the
selenium is selenium 80 and about a
quarter of it is selenium 78 and less
than 10% for all the other isotopes this
one here I kind of snuck in selenium 82
is not a stable isotope of selenium its
radioactive so let's take a look at I
just like to look at the the isotopes
that are radioactive but lasts a little
longer than a minute so this you know
there's a chance of actually seeing some
of that stuff around and you can see
that these have half-lives from a few
minutes to well this one here selenium
79 is a half-life of 300,000 years but
selenium 82 remember that one that snuck
in there under the stuff that's actually
still found in nature notice it has a
half-life of a hundred and of 10 to the
20th years a one with 2000 either way
it's been around for a long time and
it's going to be around for a long time
as a matter of fact after all of these
elements have decayed and are gone
selenium 82
is still gonna be there because it's
it's has a half-life that is very long I
mean the universe is only what 13.8
billion years so that's that would be
like ten to the ninth
ten to the tenth years so the universe
is act that this this is a half-life of
this is actually seven and a quarter
billion times the age of the universe
it's it's not very radioactive right if
you had a lump of it you might even have
a hard time detecting it was radioactive
so selenium is a it's a nonmetal really
it's a metalloid here I have some here
in case you want to come up and see some
after this is what it looks like it's if
you can come up and see this but don't
take it out of the plastic bag because
it's it's mildly toxic so rather you not
touch it the element itself but you'll
be able to feel that it's kind of
brittle it's kind of almost glassy in
nature actually can see some of the
fractures here are concluding fractures
like you see glass break it's a it's
kind of a middle density element it has
a density of a little less than five
grams per cubic centimeter everybody
knows what density is it's how much
stuff is in a given volume right
what's the density of water one gram for
every cubic centimeter yeah here's some
other densities down here so you can see
that the density of selenium is a it's a
little denser than I mean it's little
iron is a little denser than selenium
leads quite a bit denser and I have over
here by the way for those of you haven't
been here before some blocks that are
made out of different materials starting
with the maple and plastic and actually
we can see those densities right here
ending in tungsten which is the most
dense element I have access to so down
here you can see tungsten and lead and
copper and iron and titanium and
aluminum and magnesium and I don't have
a block of selenium
you can feel kind of the density from
the this bag this is 100 grams of
selenium so I have a good range of
densities if you want to play with the
densities be careful if you lift up the
I have to warn you about the the
tungsten it's extremely dense so if you
lift it up both hands underneath lift it
with both hands don't drop it on your
foot it will leave a mark
Gold is by the way Gold is this in case
you're interested Gold is the same
density as tungsten so lifting that
brick of tungsten is the same thing as
lifting the same sized brick of gold so
you'll get a feel for what gold feels
like on the hardness scale again this is
Mohs scale of hardness for you people
who know your geology one is the softest
one of the softest thing like talc is
one that's you can scratch it with your
fingernail and ten is diamond selenium
is right there so it's pretty soft has a
softness of about two on the Mohs scale
[Music]
so about the same as sulfur which we
have seen before
and calcium we've seen before but I
couldn't take calcium out of the jar
pretty soft element it's this has
actually fairly low melting point there
it is way down there its melting point
is only 221 degrees C so about twice as
hot as boiling water yeah you don't have
to really heat this up very much to get
it to melt as tempting as it was to melt
that into one block I resisted the
temptation didn't want to kill myself
boiling temperatures I mean boiling
temperatures just a little bit higher
boiling point is a 685 so again pretty
low we're not in the thousands of
degrees like we are with metals or like
six thousand degrees with with tungsten
we know that tungsten has a high melting
point because it's glowing white-hot up
here and still not melting in light
bulbs if you could still get tungsten
light bulbs because we're approaching
the end of the periodic table where the
noble gases are that electrons are being
held closer and closer and closer to the
nucleus and so the
the selenium atom is actually fairly
small this is just comparing it to the
hydrogen atom and that will get even
smaller as we progress on to Krypton in
three months it has kind of a pretty
spectrum but not one that I can show you
because I can't put it in a flame but it
has lines each one of these lines that
you see here is uniquely made by
selenium so by if you see that pattern
in a spectrum you know you have selenium
we can tell it's a very useful tool in
virtually all of the sciences so what's
it used for we mentioned in metallurgy
it's used to refine metals so one of the
metals that is really used to refine as
manganese one of those ones we've
already hit number 25 you use selenium
compounds to purify manganese and this
is during the again manganese is
separated using electrodes and from a
solution and when you add selenium
dioxide to that solution it kind of
decreases the power necessary to to
plate the manganese out onto the
electrode so it saves a lot of money so
China is the largest consumer of
selenium and for this purpose for every
ton of manganese that you refine you
need about two kilograms of selenium
dioxide if you're going to make your
fixtures in your bathroom or your
kitchen out of brass well brass often
has a lot of lead in it so you would
like to not have lead in your fixtures
in your kitchen in your bathroom because
you don't want to be drinking it and so
there is a way to make lead-free brass
and you substitute lead you substitute
selenium for the ledge so you substitute
a slightly less toxic material for a
more toxic material and you get
lead-free brass out of it that was
actually kind of mandated by the Safe
Drinking Water Act of 1974 it's actually
marketed as something called enviro
brass I like market
you can also use selenium for photocells
for first solar cells rather this is
solar cell that where you actually have
to plate several layers of material and
those layers are copper indium gallium
and selenium and you can plate them on
thin very thin plastic pieces which
means you can make them bendable this is
not as efficient as your standard
silicon photocell that you would find
for instance on the roof of the Explorer
time right above our head there are five
thousand eight hundred and seventy four
solar panels that are generating power
hopefully hopefully one of these days
we're going to get to two to zero
use of PG&E but we're working on it
we're gonna be we're gonna be Net Zero
one of these days so this can selenium
can be used to convert power from
sunlight into electricity directly
another one of those big uses that you
saw in that usage chart was glass
manufacturing if there's any iron
impurities in glass it kind of makes the
glass greenish and by adding selenium
usually as a selenium compound it
actually can change the color of glass
and make it a little redder so by adding
a little selenium you can cancel the
green out and make clear or glass or if
you want to go a little further you can
add even more selenium and use it as a
red dye in your glass and make this
beautiful colored glass using selenium
or you can also use it as a glaze in
pottery so here's a saline the red glaze
there is a selenium glaze there's a
really beautiful color super-high-tech
let's go super high-tech this looks kind
of ancient Greek but let's go super
high-tech if you can make very very
small particles and I mean nanometer
sized particles billionths of a meter in
diameter they actually when they're
exposed to blue or ultraviolet light
will fluoresce and the color the fayth
fluoresce depends on the size of the
particle
which means that you can tune the color
of fluorescence these little tiny
particles are made out of either cadmium
selenide or lead solenoid so there's
selenium involved here and these things
are called quantum dots I love that name
inside of these these vials here are
liquid containing quantum dots and in
this one right here the quantum dots are
a little bit larger than the dots here
these are a little larger than the dots
here these are a little larger than the
docs here but you really can't tell
until I light it up with ultraviolet
light so here's what happens when you
light it up with ultraviolet light they
ooh yes the right protocol these are
glowing because of the very tiny
particles the particles in the red are
about twice the size as the particles in
the green they're actually I have a
slide showing that case you couldn't see
that from the back same thing but isn't
that beautiful but the ability to be
able to tune the color that it gives off
just by manufacturing that dot the
little particles the quantum dots the
correct size is a really interesting
technology for instance let me look at
one more slide technical slide so here
you can I can't point with a flash with
an ultraviolet flashlight there we go so
you can see here that the red here is
being made with six nanometer sized
particles whereas the green is at about
two and a half nanometers particles
there's kind of a cyan color which I
don't have here down to two nanometer
particles the fact that you can tune
where the peak is by manufacturing these
little dust motes there lexing much
smaller than dust motes these little
particles means that you can actually
make a fluorescent thing that that might
be useful to you for instance there is
if you're looking at the kind of
displays like I'm looking at here a LCD
display there's what there's a white
light big panel that white slit lights
up white there's a liquid crystal panel
that
has little dots in it that you can turn
on and off you can make them transparent
or opaque black and then in front of
that there are there's a an array of
colored filters red green and blue
colored filters well if you're just
taking white light and you're filtering
it with the filters the filters are
coming out probably 90% of the light
you're not getting a lot of the light
from here through the colored filters on
the front but if you could make the
colors that the panel gives off the
white panel specific to the filters
you'd get a lot more light through and
you can make things a lot more saturated
and there are now televisions cue LED
televisions is the brita is the brand
name for them and that use a back
backlight of quantum dots that make just
the red proper red color just that
proper green colors just a proper blue
color to get through the colored filters
in the front much more efficient really
cool really cool technology this was
made by a company name called nano sis
they're down in just down in Mountain
View they make little tiny particles the
very first blue LEDs were zinc selenide
LEDs that has been supplanted now now
they're gallium arsenide that relates
back to last week last month but they
the very first blue LEDs were selenium
based if you're a photographer well you
have to be a photographer not a digital
photographer if you're like me and I
used to run a darkroom where we actually
had solutions you know you put the print
in and everything and we had something
called selenium toner and selenium toner
would take a black-and-white print and
you could kind of tone it you could make
it a different color
here's an example so take a
black-and-white print and you'd soak the
paper in selenium toner and even you
would get something that might look like
this a kind of a sepia color although
selenium toner would also do some other
interesting things as well
it covers more than Prince though if you
have your selenium in the form of an
acid Selenas acid h2so4 as and aluminum
and you can kind of stain those things
black and that's for antiquing or you
can also there's a version of this also
for steel we use a lot of the steel
version in the museum here to to color
the steel exhibits parts of the exhibits
black here's an example of the black
coating that you get from those from
Salinas acid watch and these mechanical
parts here one thing that you may have
at home that has selenium in it if you
have dandruff shampoo you ever wonder
why I was called selsun blue selsun blue
has selenium in it it's not because it
doesn't have a selsun motor this is the
kind of motor that's called the selsun
motor but no selenium selsun blue has as
a medic as the active ingredient yes
selenium sulfide that is the only active
ingredient in tender shampoo and it's so
it's selenium based if you're an
electronics person you go back in time a
little bit you may recognize this device
here but you have to be a little older
to recognize this this is what would be
called a diode nowadays back then this
is called a selenium rectifier and those
plates that you see have coatings of
selenium on them as a matter of fact if
you look at the diagram here you can see
there's cadmium selenide right there and
it meets up with an electrode of tin and
current here will flow in one direction
but not the other direction it's a diode
that's what diodes do but this actually
has another interesting quality to it
and that is if you try to send
electricity through it backwards it will
not allow the electricity to go through
backwards until you raise the
voltage enough and then it'll it'll
conduct backwards so this is also useful
is still used in anti surge if you have
an outlet strip that has a surge
protector built in it has a couple of
these devices in it so that if the
voltage builds up really high they start
conducting and they form a short so the
high voltage doesn't get to your
electronics it it shorts out in the
outlet strip and may burn out the outlet
strip but who cares it protected your
computer okay one of the more
interesting uses of selenium was
discovered by this guy I had to include
him because I just love the name
Willoughby will it be Smith he
discovered that selenium changes how
conductive it is depending on how much
light is falling on it that's actually a
pretty cool thing because that means you
could use it to measure how much light
is hitting something so for instance in
a device like this again for
photographers who have been around a
little while you might recognize the
gold siekaniec
flash the sekonic light meter and the
sekonic light meter has selenium based
photo cells here and here and that
allows you to measure the amount of
light hitting your subject or reflecting
off your subject which gets us to one
more really interesting application of
photo conductivity and selenium this guy
Chester Carlson was playing around with
trying to make copies of things he was
the first pirate he was trying to make
copies of things but the copy the ways
you can make copies up to that time all
involved a wet process where you had to
get the paper wet he wanted to make a
dry process and so he invented a process
that was completely dry but he needed a
photosensitive surface that would
discharge when light fell on it and he
chose selenium as one of his substances
you can use sulfur too by the way
just pure sulfur but he started out and
invented this process which we now call
xerography from zeroes meaning dry and
graphy meaning writing and he his very
first Xerox because they didn't call it
zero expect then his very first zur
graphic copy was just the date and the
place that he copied the made the copy
in surprisingly that's what the first
copy was it wasn't a picture of his butt
so you know this of course made him
quite wealthy he was working for he
founded a company called the hallowed
company which later got changed to Xerox
and it was such a success that he even
had a stamp made of hims his likeness
here's his first patent by the way you
can look it up and you may notice that
if you read through the patents real
carefully you'll find that selenium is
in there as the photosensitive surface
that led to the very first Xerox copiers
office copier this was a revolution this
thing could produce seven copies a
minute seven copies a minute yeah it was
a wonder there are some really great
commercials on there look up the Xerox
commercials on YouTube they're very
humorous and you can see how things have
changed in the office since the
commercial is made inside of that copier
was and really one of the revolutions of
Xerox was that everything was done on a
drum so you could continuously turn the
drum and make the copies there's the
drum the drum had a surface that was
coated with selenium this drum
everything happened on the drum it was
exposed the toner particles were
attracted to it you put a piece of paper
nearby you attracted the toner particles
away from the paper it all happened
around the drum very very cool process
if you want to know more about this
xerographic process I highly recommend
that you go on the web here's the web
address so if you want after I'll bring
this light up after if you want you can
take a picture of it this is a
a program that was made long time ago by
artist Tim hongcun called the secret
life of machines and he did eighteen of
them telling you how different machines
worked this one season three episode 6
the last last one was the photocopier
and Tim by the way who is an artist in
residence here as well comes here almost
every summer Tim goes through the
xerographic process and shows you
exactly what happens inside that copier
it's a really wonderful process it
really is I highly recommend this here's
another place where you may have
encountered selenium if you've ever
stood in front of an x-ray one of these
plates holding onto the bars above
getting a chest x-ray
the sensors behind the plastic here are
made out of selenium the x-ray sensors
now the selenium was actually about
twice as sensitive as film which meant
that they could take the same x-ray with
half the number of the amount of
radiation so this was a really nice
breakthrough in the human body selenium
is a an element that you have about 13
to 20 milligrams of selenium inside your
body
it's a often given to you as a dietary
supplement usually you only take maybe
50 to 70 milligrams and micrograms per
day of selenium so it's not a super
abundant element in your body but you do
need it it's used it's toxic if you take
it in large amounts that's why I want to
keep that in the plastic bag but it's
present in all animals it's a you can
actually give it too it's actually
included in infant formula to make sure
that infants are given the proper amount
of if you feed your baby formula and
it's important in your thyroid gland
almost every cell that uses any thyroid
hormone uses selenium you can you don't
have to take it in supplements if you
want to take selenium in a natural form
one of the highest concentration
selenium things you can eat
our Brazil nuts which by the way are not
nuts and for most part are not grown in
Brazil just FYI they're mostly grown in
Bolivia but these have the highest known
concentrations of selenium and it's not
because they need it who knows but this
is one way that you can get your
selenium so we're sort of at the end
here so we have we're at our our haiku
stage here so here's the haiku for
today's from mary soonly
so proud to be part of each drop of
formula helping babies thrive so next
month there will be no everything
matters tails from the periodic table
we're gonna skip January but in February
we do have one coming up and it will be
bromine element number 35 and that will
be on February 21st so we hope you'll
come back for that I also still have a
couple of talks this month if you're
interested in full spectrum science we
have one coming up on mixing color so if
you're interested in why your teacher
primary school teacher lied to you when
he or she told you that the primary
colors were blue red and yellow
I'm gonna tell you why so I'm not gonna
tell you why now though so you'll have
to come either this coming Sunday one
and three or next Thursday at 8 so thank
you for coming and if you have any
questions please come up and ask play
with the density blocks come up and see
the pure selenium and hope you enjoy
tonight thank you
[Applause]
[Music]